the mind that we have is a unique place
we have enough material for years and
years and years and able to help
generation after generation it's in a
location where we can get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
we're in Utah which is known as the
mineral state and I'm with Dave Taylor
youngevity gets all its raw materials
for its plant derived minerals from Dave
so Dave why don't you kind of explain to
us what we're looking here at the wall
this is a positive plant materials big
rich stick brown band it's up there
that was a deciduous forest and that's
way cool stuff to really mess with could
you can just open it up and just look at
see all the plants when you go up and
you hold the material in your hands it
almost reminds you of a tree because you
can see each year's layer you know you
imagine the nutrition you have enough
lime you can just the middle just bite
right out but the ones I like to talk
about our mineral deficiencies because
they make up two-thirds of the essential
nutrients our bodies cannot manufacture
them we must consume them every day
either as food or supplements what I'd
like to see happen where everybody
around the world recognizes that
nutrition is so important so we've all
heard about dr. Wallach talk about
minerals and we all know that they're
important but I'll always like to phrase
it they're kind of like cofactors they
help hundreds of thousands of different
functions happen within your body so the
key thing is about taking our plant
derive minerals or products and a bark
plant derived minerals we can be assured
that we're getting all 60 essential
nutrients and we talked about humic
shale people always think shell well
isn't that rock and I like to phrase it
a different way
a million year old compost pile that has
never had enough pressure on it to turn
into coal so it's still an organic plant
material
you took that much decomposed material
and all the minerals may be thinner in
it I mean how much would you have to eat
in order to take a get that mineral
content when doc had his practice in
Portland Oregon he was having his
patients taking 30 and 40 pills you know
to get all his 90 essential nutrients a
bottle with calcium and here's a bottle
of magnesium and here's about with iron
and so you're gonna have to have 60
different bottles it was unknown
cumbersome the humic shale saved us from
having 60 different bottles everybody's
got to take the 90 and the core of that
is the humic show
[Music]
step one is obviously get the material
here and they bring the material out by
mining techniques
and we take it down to the first
processing facility and so what we have
here is an elevator that lifts the
stones up and then puts it in the tanks
so that we can start this process as
simple as that and we put it in clean
food grade tanks that are sterilized and
we basically do osmosis if you don't
understand osmosis it's like summer tea
we take a high concentration in the
image shale we control the temperature
barometric pressure and time and we're
able to leach the minerals out of humid
shale in the fulvic acid into purified
water from there it gets put through a
pasteurization and immediately packaged
in food grade transport 55-gallon
barrels talk about the testing processes
you do with the product before it even
leaves here we takin we have it tested
mold Salmonella in Syria and then we
send sample to you you guys pull your
samples again and double-check and make
sure that everything's proper on your
side from there we take it to our
various manufacturers where they either
dilute it to make the plant derive
minerals or we use the full
concentration and we add more vitamins
minerals to make our various products
but the key the base of everything is
the plant derived minerals
[Music]
the more that we can stay with a natural
product
I think the safer we are and the better
that we can put products together using
natural components the more effective we
are at overcoming challenges
[Music]
we talk about 94 life and everyone goes
well how long do I have to take it and
my answer is always really easy I go how
long do you have to breathe air how long
can you go without taking 90 essential
nutrients and that's what we're
providing for you
[Music]
you